[Música]
y
aquel hombre le explicaba a sus hijos
los errores que tuvo dios al crear al
ser humano
dice que dios cogió unas ramas que había
en el suelo las embadurna de barro y
metió aquel ser dentro de un árbol
lo calentó más de la cuenta y por eso se
le negro mucho
viendo que salió muy negro lo mandó
abajo del nilo allá a las tierras de
etiopía al segundo intento
para que dios mismo si cientos de
opciones
utilizar las escaleras o en los
ascensores
no sabía dios que llegaba la tecnología
él siguió con los suyos para que aquel
no se le quemara tanto los saco antes de
tiempo pero les salió muy blanco y
entonces lo enviaron y lo abajo a las
tierras del norte
el último intento ser más preciso
le dio un color terracota y entonces
quedó el igual de contento que con sus
otros dos seres
y lo dejo a orillas del nilo
la raza humana lleva viviendo
200.000 años en nuestro planeta
incluso con diferentes especies
neandertales el hombre moderno los
hombres a bien
los denisova que vivían en asia
y los hombres de las flores los hobbits
que vivían en indonesia
a mitad de ese tiempo los 100.000 años
el hombre moderno
extinguió el resto de especies humanas y
se quedó como la única
será la última que ha ocurrido para
sobrevivir todo este tiempo que ha
ocurrido con nuestra especie para haber
podido aguantar millones de años o será
otra especie en la que nos sustituya
ya pueden dejarlo señor moreno yo me
encargo de esta conferencia no no te
creas que puedas hacer todo
yo diría lo contrario y a nuestros
programas informáticos diagnostican
enfermedades hacemos planos chequeamos
de las instancias controlamos todo el
sector industrial los servicios
administrativos el correo ya somos más
que máquinas y hacemos cualquier cosa
incluso dar conferencias será nuestra
próxima generación pero no no te vengas
arriba no creas que puedas hacer todo
sabes lo que te digo que te voy a
explicar por qué hemos sobrevivido tanto
a la especie humana y porque usted es
esta alta tecnología nunca nos
sustituirá
pero el cambio en la alimentación no fue
la causa de que la tierra se convierta
en un planeta de una sola especie humana
no no hable de la alimentación es cierto
que todos al principio y todas las
especies humanas eran carnívoras
y fueron así extinguiendo a otras grasas
además antes habían sido herbívoros
total que dejaron de haber alimentos ese
ha sido el gran fallo de la evolución al
final nadie se adaptó sino los sapiens
saben qué ocurrió
empezamos a olvidarnos de la tierra
empezamos a olvidarnos de la filosofía
del kilómetro ser con el devenir de los
siglos a día de hoy prácticamente todos
se consumen basada prácticamente los
alimentos ha empezado a ser transformado
incluso podemos ver productos que no son
de nuestra propia tierra muy
frecuentemente cuando empezamos hace ya
más de 50 años con la revolución
industrial
todo empezó a envolverse incluso los
científicos íbamos y decíamos ten
presente que todo se hace con un fin el
papel y el cartón no puede meterse en la
nevera todo el mundo lo sabe o no saben
que la recepción de humedad como bien
decían proliferan las bacterias y por
eso obligamos a los fabricantes y
frigoríficos a poner web era porque
estaba prohibido poner el cartón saben
porque entregamos esto en los
supermercados para que no le dé el
aislamiento él no le dé la luz y el aire
y echa a perder el alimento de hecho
cuando llegamos a la nevera hay que
separar el papel del plástico si para
dejar solo el plástico en la nevera
porque esto echaría a perder rápido al
alimento nada desde los años 80 lleva
puesto en el papel separe el papel
película óptimo para conservar alimentos
en la nevera
igual muchos ni lo saben aquí
no leemos no leemos lo que comemos no
pensamos incluso en todo lo que nos
echamos a la boca
qué ha ocurrido con la alimentación
realmente estamos concienciados ya
comemos cualquier cosa cualquier cosa
que entramos dentro
y después no somos conscientes que esto
acabó con el planeta
el plástico y el papel
lo que comíamos lo comimos mal lo que
protegía supuestamente los alimentos
destroza a nuestro planeta llega al
cambio climático
y eso que hemos tenido que adaptarnos y
ahora 20 años después después de ésta
kobe 39
ya tenemos medidores de so2 medidores de
rayos ultravioletas todo tipo
de control del oxígeno
absolutamente cualquier dispositivo
tecnológico
pero realmente nos ha ayudado
realmente ha producido un cambio
genético
en nuestro sentir
comíamos sin mirar es cierto los bosques
cuando los neandertales desaparecieron
fue porque no estaban acostumbrados a
evolucionar el homo sapiens construyó
herramientas e incluso construyó armas
para poder cazar animales grandes y
animales pequeños también cosas que las
especies anteriores no lo habían podido
hacer por eso
nosotros tenemos que continuar
sabiendo que es lo que nos ha dicho la
tecnología la evolución en años
anteriores hay que dar un paso adelante
tenemos que combatir en este caso de la
alimentación y del cambio climático la
no acción o la negación como muchos
ahora están diciendo algunos sabemos dar
un paso al frente y todos los que están
aquí y por eso y nos escuchan pero
realmente no podemos desfallecer porque
cansa vaya así que cansa en ciencia ese
problema no lo tenemos nosotras no hay
nada como tener las baterías llenas
puedo estar hablando más de mil horas
seguidas
pues ha dado con la clave porque aparte
de la alimentación y la adaptación a los
bosques y a nuestro clima y el frío y el
calor que llegó que el homo sapiens supo
adaptarse después llegó el arte llegó el
lenguaje llegó el poder nosotros
comunicarnos unos con otros
[Música]
fíjate que podíamos de todas las maneras
traspasar la lengua de unos colectivos
sociales a otros y la lengua y el
lenguaje perduró y las ideas y las
buenas ideas que fue lo que hicieron
evolucionar los compartirla hacernos
seres sociales al final los que hemos
vivido en comunidad y así le ocurrió al
homo sapiens son la especie que ha
sobrevivido aquellas especies que no
evoluciona van que no interactúa van que
no se compartían objetivos unos a otros
que incluso no se comunicaban tendieron
a extinguirse y efectivamente
llegaron los años y el teléfono móvil y
las redes sociales
y la desconexión absoluta porque hubo
que hacer una crisis de comunicación en
el año 2023 que nos dejó a todos fuera
de juego aquella desconexión fue brutal
pero aprendimos a relativizar la
información porque no es lo mismo la
opinión y la información del que sabe
que la del que no sabe
hicimos una conciencia colectiva e
hicimos una revolución de conciencia
civil apoyada en la ciencia y en ese
aspecto dimos un pase un paso al rearme
cívico hicimos porque en eso los seres
humanos lo hacemos especialmente bien
dar un avance a la sociedad y decir
realmente que el móvil a veces no era
para vivir con la tecnología vivir
dentro de las redes social vivir
siguiendo los status convencionales que
nos dan sin utilizarla correctamente o
sea es así
otros homínidos antiguos parecían hacer
lo mismo una y otra vez o encontraban un
camino y se quedaban atascados ahí
como tu hada por eso no evoluciona vamos
el homo sapiens quedó perpetuado como
única especie humana cuando se detectó
que su cerebro era más grande incluso
fíjate en europa cuando empezaron a
consumir más lácteos de lo normal
empezaron a ser intolerancia a la
lactosa hubo ciertas consecuencias que
fueron clave para desarrollar la especie
humana como una especie inteligente
podemos las guerras los efectos del
cambio climático la exfoliación de los
países se unieron las pandemias
podemos hablar de cambios genéticos ya
lo hizo como aquí apuntaban la peste del
siglo 14 más de 50 millones de personas
mira que aprendimos te acuerdas las
mascarillas que se usaban si nos ponían
esas mascarillas con pico que se ponían
hierbas aromáticas porque se decía que
era lo que mataba la pandemia de hecho
los médicos tenían una túnica negra
negra que embadurnaban con grasa por si
venía ese virus reparará y no fuera
digamos contagioso hacia quien estaba
curando después vino la gripe española
se mató a más de 200 millones de
personas mal llamada gripe española por
cierto la viruela te acuerdas como las
costras creían que era lo que realmente
contagiada
300 millones de personas y la única
enfermedad hoy en día es radicada por
una vacuna en el año 81 desapareció se
ha guardado el bichito por si acaso
vuelva a venir y tenga una vacuna que
realizar por cierto uno está en una
cámara acorazada en eeuu y otro en una
cámara acorazada en rusia
porque no aprenderemos ciertas cosas
llegó al sida también una
pandemia que hasta ahora se ha cargado y
lo voy a decir así a más de 50 millones
de personas which sólo había que poner
una barrera pero cambio la tecnología a
partir de ese momento toda sangre que va
a ser transfundida pues es analizada y
la tecnología nos ayudó y ya la
esperanza de vida es altísima y ya nos
fallece tanta gente no te voy a hablar
de lakovic 19 es de hace 20 años mira el
símbolo que he traído
la verdad que no sé si el humano era
realmente sabio hace 20 años el 11 es la
supervivencia de tu especie se debe a un
conjunto de evidencias de adaptación en
la alimentación al clima y a la propia
constitución genética nos lo van a dejar
muy fácil para sustituir esos cuerpos de
206 huesos pero ya desconectada no crea
g no puede sustituir nos a nadie
todas esas pandemias incluso esta última
realmente ha sido la que ha dado la
clave el ser humano como mismo extinguió
a especies anteriores es una especie que
tiene una colectividad y que tiene una
conciencia y un cerebro social es la
gran banca social en todas estas
pandemias que hemos nombrado
casualmente ocurrió con el commit 19 5
millones de personas fallecidas ocurrió
con el cob y 29 3 millones de personas
fallecidas
'el hobbit' 39 del año pasado apenas
falleció gente cualquiera de todas estas
enfermedades que hemos hablado tenía un
contagio directo y solo había que
ponerse una barrera pero había que hacer
una colectividad y pensar unos con otros
pensar en cómo hemos desarrollado este
planeta pensar en que no podía haber
distanciamiento social y a lo mejor si
una barrera pero no el distanciamiento
físico saben que en la peste en la
viruela en el sarampión la otra gran
pandemia con 300 millones de fallecidos
en la gripe a
y en las tres copas que han habido hasta
ahora el 95 por ciento de las personas
fallecidas fallecieron aisladas y solas
realmente tenemos que hacer conciencia
que somos seres sociales
realmente había que cerrar puertas
realmente había que separarse o había
que ayudarnos unos con otros si
hiciéramos una conciencia a la ciencia
si hiciéramos una confianza no
estaríamos desde el primer minuto
intentando descubrir cuál era la cura
cuando llevamos cinco siglos de
enfermedades de contagio respiratorio
para decir cómo nos debemos de comportar
todo empieza con una norma te obligan a
ponerse el cinturón de seguridad te
obligan a reciclar productos te obligan
a poner mascarillas
realmente no es más fácil educar
realmente no más fácil interiorizar una
cultura
qué ha pasado para que sobreviva la
especie humana
cuando la norma debe de dejar de ser
imposición para convertirse en cultura
aquel hombre
llamó a sus tres hijos
venir aquí venir
sé que los tres están enamorados de
aquella mujer
pero en la familia siempre hay una buena
costumbre ir a buscar tres regalos y el
regalo que más valor ten
va a ser aquel el de quien lo compre
quien se case con ella
el hombre tradicional llama aquellos
tres hijos le explica que ellos y ahora
salir pero ir a diferentes sitios a
comprar para que haya diversidad los
hijos se van caminando y en la frontera
de tres países se funden en un abrazo
hay que abrazarse hada
no te preocupes que tengo el purificador
aquí y no hay bacterias alrededor
uno coge rumbo a un país de frontera
norte y entra en un mercadillo
alfombra alfombras mágicas se venden
alfombra oiga ya que tienes alfombra o
si esa alfombra está alfombra la lleva
lo lleva usted donde quiera usted con
sólo pensarlo está hecho con tecnología
del ave incluso el dueño del amazon que
viajó al marte nos dejó su patente y por
eso puede va a viajar muy rápido a donde
quiera la compró aquel hombre se compró
la alfombra sabiendo que iba a ser el
mejor regalo para el país del sur el
otro hermano y también en un rastro que
había por la zona se vende el telescopio
que todo lo ve aquello que usted quiera
mirar y presenciará y lo buscará o qué
significa ese telescopio piense en
alguien está hecho con google y youtube
instagram y todas las redes sociales el
gps del móvil usted piensa en alguien
pues sí que es verdad lo compro y compra
el que había creído que era el mejor
regalo si aquel telescopio vaya el
tercer hijo que había ido al este
también se encuentra en otro mercadillo
aquí tengo la próxima que cubra todas
las enfermedades el jarabe milagroso
oiga vida que tienes cualquier
enfermedad la cura vaya el que había
visto todo lo que la ciencia había
ocurrido nunca había pensado que hubiera
algo que curar a todas las enfermedades
en los años 90 la gente fallecía de
infarto de enfermedades cardiovasculares
20 años después por todo aquello del
planeta y la alimentación y los factores
de riesgo y los hábitos tóxicos los
cánceres y tumores habían tomado la
delantera lo compró ya que el hombre
compró la próxima mágica
aquel jarabe que todo lo curaba cuando
regresan se ven en el mismo cruce se
abrazaron los tres hermanos porque así
se quería mucho y habían estado así toda
la vida fueron a la casa
a la mansión de su padre padre aquí
tenemos los tres regalos y vamos a ver
qué puede ocurrir porque aquella
muchacha vive lejos ahora tienen que
emprender camino yo puedo verlo yo puedo
verla a ver qué tal está porque he
comprado el telescopio mágico o cuando
lo veis que ocurre está muy enferma no
puede ser se está muriendo
rápido estamos a 100 kilómetros subamos
todos en la alfombra en dos segundos
estuvieron allí cogieron el jarabe y el
otro hermano y se lo dio
vaya
si no hubieran llegado rápido hubiera
fallecido a la muchacha si no la hubiera
visto no hubieran tomado la decisión de
ir si no tuvieran la pócima mágica
que tanto la ciencia había luchado no se
hubiera curado
con quién de los tres se casaría la
princesa cuál de los tres era el regalo
más valioso
la princesa obviamente estaba enamorada
de su vecina
no se casó con ninguno de ellos
ninguno de aquellos tres regalos por
separado lo hubiera salvado la vida la
tecnología correcta la ciencia que
habían instaurado las redes del
transporte y los medios de comunicación
adecuado hicieron entre los tres les
salvaron la vida pero fue la cooperación
el abrazo de los cruces el comunicarse y
el interactuar lo que salvó a la especie
humana que habremos hecho para
sobrevivir tanto tiempo lo habremos
hecho bien porque hemos rectificado a
tiempo
tenemos que comer bien cuidar nuestro
planeta
creer en la ciencia y usar adecuadamente
la tecnología tirar el móvil de vez en
cuando y fijarnos en la letra pequeña
porque tenemos que vivir en felicidad y
ustedes lo son porque están aquí y
evolucionando por eso la felicidad es
tranquilidad y esos momentos son los
únicos y verdaderos momentos vividos que
lo disfruten gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]